hello everyone this is woman's
grandmaster sabina feuster
welcome back to san luis chess club's
youtube channel
for today i have prepared for you some
very interesting
studies and i've mixed the themes
previous weeks i've shown
zugsvang stylemate promotion under
promotion
and now i've decided for
today's uh video
and stream to show you multiple
um themes and um
hopefully you guys will enjoy it without
further ado let us get started
all right so the first
the first position that i have set up
here for you is actually a study i'm not
exactly sure who has composed this study
but um
insane in the endgame indeed um
that that's technically the the name of
the
[Music]
of today's class but um
i like to i mean i decided to to focus
on studies
which are also typically in game studies
my dad has shared this study with me
today and he wanted to make sure
i'm going to say that it was from him
and i did for the first time in this
month
i decided to go visit him he doesn't
live that far away but
um basically you know i was
i was very busy with teaching and i
haven't had the chance but today
as we met it's always like this in my
family it's always been like this we had
like a
really fun talk about chess we're always
talking about chess
these days there's something else uh
we're talking cryptocurrency as well but
that's for another time for another
stream right now let's focus on chess
and this is a study that he gave me and
since i didn't have a board close by i
was like just tell me the position i'm
going to try to solve it blindfolded
he's like no no no but it's not so easy
there are lots of pawns you don't know
what to do it's like
it doesn't matter just give me the
position i'm going to try to solve it
and um surprisingly i actually managed
to do it uh considering that i'm
not i haven't been working on just on my
on my own very much so
i decided to share it with you as the
first kind of like
get in shape study so what do you guys
think about this position
um unfortunately i do not know the
author
of this position but um
it is clear that white is trying to win
and it's going to be a zugswang
idea which is a theme that i've
discussed previously
in my streams it's a theme that i enjoy
very much zugswang and stylemate
are two of my favorite themes i think in
studies and um
and yeah so what do you guys think
if you're going to watch this later be
sure to pause the video
if you are watching right now uh
well i can let you think about it
a little bit more but i will have to
show the solutions so
um basically the idea is
that black is
stuck here with the bishop so he's not
going to be able to
move it away and he's basically going to
make these two moves
he will go back king king to king b1
if you are able to create the right
restrictions so that
you know the king cannot move anywhere
so someone is saying bishop d5 um it's
actually not bishop d5 the point is if
you play bishop d5
in this position then uh black can
promote
to something you're going to capture
that pawn
and then he's going to escape with the
king because now you don't really have a
way to keep him there
he's threatening to promote in this
position
and now if you're checking him for
example
he can just run away and
the best thing you can do is maybe just
give a couple of checks
then go bishop e4 stop the pawn from
promoting
they can promote to whatever they want
you take and this is not going to be
winning even if you win those two pawns
two bishops versus one bishop should be
a draw
so it is very important to keep that in
mind and try to avoid
um avoid letting them
letting them escape with the king it is
very important to be careful
about that yes
all right so the idea here is to make
sure that when the king goes to e2 he's
not going to be able to escape so the
key
to do is to restrict the a3 square
and this is the reason why i love
studies because it makes you think it
makes you
come up with an idea yes it is true
sometimes there are lines that are
forced but that also helps you
become more familiar with the
calculation so in this position we're
going to play bishop d6 that is the
correct first move for
white restricting that square now
what is black going to do he can try we
can try pretty much anything but
uh i think b5 kind of makes sense he can
try king a2 as well
but if that happens um we're going to
check them
right he goes king b1
i hope i i hope i put the the position
correctly
i hope i have put it correctly the way
he has shown it to me
and what do we do now
can we capture this pawn
and if he plays b5
i'm not hearing moves from you guys
which is
sad it is sad what do you do in this
position with white
bishop takes h2
well we'll get back to that bishop takes
h2 he's pushing b4
now right now you have to be careful
because if he gets to play b3
if he gets to play b3 and you're not
careful he will escape with the king so
you have to be very careful
all right we can play bishop bishop f4
for example he's going to play b3
and now he has this move right
so we are we're going to take advantage
of it and we're going to go king c3
he needs to go over there we are going
to capture this paw he cannot go king a3
because of the mate
but we'll get back we'll get back to it
he has to go king to p1
bishop b4 okay we'll get back to that
now we can just move the bishop
somewhere he will play king c1 and
how is the winning idea how do we get to
win
bishop a3 he goes king b1 now what
i think you guys are behind or i am
behind
this room is behind something is behind
bishop c2 king c1 and then you know if
you're not careful he's going to
to have the promotion idea
you can try to do a triangulation or
something
and i can see one kingdo2 if you want to
he's gonna go king b1
but then what do you do
bishop somewhere far away he will come
back in c1
bishop g5 check he will go king b1 and
then what is your winning idea
because the best way you can win is if
you somehow
manage to kind of restrict him somehow
but
um but i don't know
you guys want to go back to the to the
position i can go back to the position
so
bishop d6 right
what did we say i said b5 but if he
plays king a2
right
bishop d5 check king b1
how do we win
you guys are saying bishop b4 here i see
and i'm gonna play b5
king takes d2 h1 queen
bishop takes h1 king a2
bishop d5 check king b1
and now bishop a3 right
that's the idea all right someone i
think someone i think
found it b4 and now we're waiting for it
to take the bishop we go bishop b3
and when they take we can play king to
d1
and whenever they push a2 we've got a
checkmate
this is basically the idea you have to
be very careful
i wanted to see what you guys are saying
but bishop d6
is the correct move in this position and
if they play b5
we're basically doing the same thing
it's very important to
blockade this pawn first so that it
doesn't get to push further because you
want
to have the opportunity for it to take
your bishop
um and you need to make sure you're
blockading b32 so you saw in the other
line
maybe you're winning but if you let him
play b3 it's
it makes it more complicated so when
black plays there we're checking him
right and since we cannot move the
bishop here just yet because there's
promotion
we need to do this but as they promote
the pawn and that's why it was very
important for the pawn to be there
the king has to go to a2 now he's on
stalemate position so we have to let
them free
square and now this is a very important
move so the pawn cannot come there so
we don't take it and then as i said
waiting move and made so i really hope
you guys like this idea i
i thought it was really fun because you
have to be a little bit careful with
what black is doing
but in the same time you know you've got
the style mating idea
and um and the zuk's back idea
all right let's go on to the next
position
and this is a position that i had
actually from previous time but i didn't
get the chance to
uh go over until the end
so in this position it is white to move
of course
um and
and um black is trying to create a
fortress we have
it it's a position that could certainly
happen in the game
created by antimon and it could
certainly happen in a game
the point is that uh
black is trying to create a fortress if
somehow they manage
to create a fortress then they should be
able to
to make a draw but white is stopping
black
from creating a fortress so what ideas
do you guys have
in this position because we have this
past f pawn that we're trying to promote
and black is going to try to restrict it
the knight wants to come in
and um there's a there's there are ideas
with bishop h3 bishop
seeks to stop the pawn from promoting so
it is really it is really a matter of uh
being super precise with white in order
to stop black and
again it's a it's a position that could
certainly happen in a game
the first move that you should think
about in this position is f6
the point is this of this move is of
course to go promote the pawn
and black's only chance to save himself
here is to play knight c6
check and here it is very important
where you're moving the king
because as i said fortress is something
that black is trying to create
so you can go king c7 and king c8 one of
the moves
is correct the other one is a mystic
king c7
is actually the mistake the point is
that
now black plays knight d4 if the knight
gets to e6 he's going to be able
to stop the f pawn from promoting if you
push f7 now there's a check you will
bring the king to attack the knight
of course and now knight the faint you
are attacking the knight once again but
after night you shall know knight g6 but
knight h7
black manages to make a draw because it
is impossible
for white to get rid of this knight
because of the placement of the bishop
you also cannot bring in your knight the
way you probably would want to
to bring it to f6 if you're trying these
checks and bringing in the knight like
this somehow
then black and simply play bishop here
restrict your knight this we're having
some kind of a domination
idea theme the bishop restricting the
knight
and unfortunately for white there's no
way
to to um create a progress in this
position because regardless of where the
knight goes
the bishop will be able to go either on
d5 or on h5
sacrifice for the pawn and black will be
able to
uh basically save the game because
um you know you won't lose the knight
after you sacrifice the bishop if needed
you sacrifice it for the pawn and then
uh you know the knight comes back home
and bishop at night versus knight should
be a draw same as bishop and knight
versus
bishop all right
so for example here if you're not going
to play f7
and you're considering give this
interesting check
so that you deflect black's knight away
from the f
pawn and now you're thinking oh i'm just
going to play f7 and
well i'm winning because i'm promoting
and there's no way for black to stop the
pawn
yes you may think this way but basically
after knight takes g6
um promotion it is somewhat crazy i know
but you guys hopefully have seen this
kind of ideas before
when it's usually two knights are able
to somehow create a fortress
and the queen cannot win the game while
in this case we'll have a knight in the
bishop
and if black places the knight in e4 if
you're looking at this position
there will be no way for white's king to
approach black's king you see
all of these squares around the king are
controlled
the knight is protected and the king
just move can move back and forth
and there will be no way for white to
progress the position or approach with
the king to try to win
this is a really cool super cool idea of
fortress so fortresses are very very
very important in end games and other
kinds of games
other kinds of positions too middle
games too but specifically
end games when you have material
disadvantage you can often find
a way to create some restriction
against your opponent so that you don't
let them to progress the position and
try to beat you
so that is something very very important
there's no progress here
keep that in mind that's why king c7 is
unfortunately a mistake because you're
staying on those kind of patterns
that allow this to be uh to be happening
so
after 96 check the correct move for
white is actually king c8 and this is
what i love
about this position because you know now
what do you do how do you do the things
can you do them as you did before
playing knight d4
you can try but it's not going to work
we're going to see in a second but i
also want to
um show you that instead of this bit of
h3
check is an option two for black but now
we go king
c7 and what's the difference well now
when you play f7
check king to d6
now uh the knight has to go to f8 as we
did before right king d7
and now um if you go knight to h7
there's 94
and now white is threatening one of
these two moves and there's no way for
you to stop them and that's because
black had to move or moved it well to
check
the bishop from here so now the bishop
cannot be capturing tonight
after knight g6 check um king f6 is
going to be played
and if you go knight of fate once again
this knight
can be brought
here and then white shall be able to to
get rid of this knight from my fate
and eventually win the game we are
threatening b56
and then try to trade the knight and
and white is going to be winning so
that's the reason why
knight d4 is the move that black
could try to play here and we can try to
see if we can get the same line but
unfortunately
we do not get the same line because
after this check
knight fakes oh by the way we have to
give this check
f7 will not work because of
96 once again right and this is the same
exact same idea when the knight mate
makes it here and because of the
placement of
uh black's bishop white does not have a
way for the knight
to come and trade his knight in h7 so 92
this is where you're deflecting the
knight and now it is also very very
important to come up with a good idea
because if you push
then there's going to be knight takes g3
and we've already seen this idea so it
doesn't make sense
to see it again there's no wait for
white's king to progress we can just sit
with the king
back and forth and it's going to be a
draw
but here uh bishop f to check
that is the correct move for white so f2
check
and king takes f2 and now f7 because
basically you want to promote
with check and restrict them from
getting that fortress
if knight g3 will promote her queen king
g1
and now you have to be careful not to
allow black's knight to get to e4 but
you have a few checks
that actually help you here check for
example king h1
now check and queen to f4
so if you manage to pin the knight in
this fashion
then clearly you're going to have a
winning idea because now after king a6
uh you bring in your king and this is
not the same kind of restriction as it
was before because now
black's king is not super protected so
now if
if white's king manages to make it to
h5 then there will be elite in h4 so it
is very important
every single piece the weight is placed
it should be important in the
figuring out if the position is going to
be draw or not
so this is a really cool idea bishop f2
check
and f7 once again there's no way for
black to create that fortress
i think there was one more line i wanted
to show after king
king g1 and then queen c5
check
if for example black says you know what
i'm going to play
knight f1 or bishop f1 that's fine
because you're still
bringing in your king and he's going to
be bound
to stay there and he's going to be super
passive and that's the reason why
we will be able to win with white
because the king can approach his very
passive
and uh and white will be winning
i hope you like this position it's a
little bit cool
to remind ourselves about fortresses
here i have
another position what do you guys think
about this position white to move
so technically considering that
um white is um
you know two points closer promotion
specifically this be one
um you're thinking okay well he can try
to promote but guess what i have
i've brought white's king in the corner
with my
knight and bishop i should be able to
have amazing idea
should be able to come up with something
and yeah you should be able to come up
with something but
but let's not forget there's a b-pawn
that can be promoted so it is very
important
the theme of this one is double
deflection
um b7 b7 indeed
b7 is the move to consider in this
position with white
if you are playing knight somewhere like
for example knight d7
it's not going to work because you're
even going to be losing because he can
play king sees
two and you know the the point of this
move is to try to control the promotion
square and to take the knight away from
the attack but since
b7 works because he cannot take the
knife due to the promotion
then this move doesn't make that much
sense basically but
let's just see it anyway so b7 and now
black manages to make you check king a2
and hopefully you guys see the mate here
because white does not have a way to
promote the tempo and that's why the
correct move is bishop e2 and we're
threading knight c3 mate
and there is no way no single way that
white is going to be able to save this
position
it's game over it's really important to
keep in mind that if you have the king
close to the center
or in the center and their positions
with knights and bishops
that is the square the same color corner
as the bishop that's where you know the
knight and bishop want to bring
the other side's king
so 97 unfortunately this move
unfortunately does not work but
not to be worried okay because we can
come up with a really good idea instead
and we can push b7
after b7 we're threatening promotion and
there are few moves that black can make
bishop d6 seems the most natural one if
he's trying to
create that mating pattern right now
it's not going to work and keep
very well in mind that there's a
promotion with track happening so you
cannot do that
now if you're trying to go for example
king c2 followed by bishop b2
uh white will castle and then bishop b2
and you're saying oh
it's me the next move whatever awesome
no there's this check
and once you move the king white has
many ways to win but
probably could even take the knight this
is the easiest one
and then march the f pawn and win with
the f pawn
so you really need to be careful on how
you're going to do things
and that's the reason why in this
position where whiter is pushing
pawn to promote black has to play bishop
d6
stopping the pawn for promotion but by
doing so he's also taking the bishop
away
from a potential mating idea so he has
to be very careful
well why to be more careful knight d7
threatening to promote and when he's
bishop after which we'll have the f
pawn with which you can win two or maybe
you start marching the f pawn
and then with the bishop alone he will
not be able to stop two pawns on
opposite diagonals right
if you have for example opposite color
bishops you probably have seen
many times positions where the bishop
stays on one diagonal
and it stops both past pawns of the
opponent
well in this case it's not like that the
pawns are on separate diagonals and
that's the reason why the bishop cannot
stop
and and um and
and black would be losing in this
position all right
so knight e3
attacking this pawn f6
and now um knight c2 check
and here we have multiple options and
once again it is time to think
and come up with the correct square
what do you guys think where is the
correct square for white king
gotta push we cannot push its check we
need to we need to move our king
um so we can go k2 king b2 or king b1
now i'll start with the bad ones and
we'll see for example if we go
king b2 this would not be such a good
idea because
in this position black can play knight
to d4 so the knight
is is uh is joining
the stopping of those plus pawns the
stopping of the pawns you go here
and then he goes here he's stopping of
the past pawns
and although your king is able
to free to move it's not going to work
because there's checkpoint
and um you don't really have many moves
to actually help yourself
uh for example if you just sit with the
king up here or something
then he's going to try to keep you
restricted and if you're not careful
maybe he will even have a mating idea
so you have to keep that in mind okay be
very very cautious about this if king a2
is pretty much the same thing check king
b3
and then knight c6 stopping that pawn
from promoting with the with the bishop
or stopping the other one
but also keeping restricted white's king
and he's not going to be able to win
here in any way
all right but the correct move was king
to b1
why not b8 queen someone was asking i'm
not sure in which line
but um you couldn't instead of king b3 i
mean king b3 was with tempo and here
b8 queen we're just capturing with the
knight and then when they take back we
can take it
and we have sufficient time to come back
and stop that c
pawn f pawn sorry f pawn
if um yeah
that's the reason why you're not
promoting you don't have sufficient time
to
pick them and the position is going to
be a
draw so white is planking to b1
in this position this is the correct
move here
94 and now f7
what's the difference between these two
because you can still play 96
or 96 so we'll try to see knight c6
what do you guys think would be the
correct answer for white in order to be
able to win this position
the correct move and very gorgeous i
think it's super gorgeous now because
you see both pieces restricting the
pawns for promoting you think
nothing is gonna happen it should be a
draw but no it's not gonna be a draw
because
knight to e5 is an amazingly beautiful
move
you're trying to deflect either one of
these pieces so that you can promote
well mostly the bishop you would love to
deflect it
so that you can promote but he will not
leave
he will go to knight b8 in case he
captures here
once again you can promote whichever you
want and then you're going to promote
the second pawn and white is winning
so after 95
black plays knight uh b8 and he's
thinking with that knight he's gonna
stop the v
pawn with the bishop he's going to stop
the f1
everything should be perfectly fine
amazing
but no not amazing because oopsie
someone forgot about attack bishop the
king has to move
and white takes the bishop after which
the position
is pretty uh pretty winning for white
there is no way to stop both pawns 97
doesn't work we can promote
whichever one of the pawns we want and
after that we're promoting the other one
and we are winning so very very
important
knight c6 all right let's try 96 but
it will be something very similar so
in this position basically both players
have something very clear in mind black
is trying to stop white from promoting
white is trying to promote deflect one
of the pieces
and then be able to win with the other
pawn
uh and uh that's you guys remember the
other idea when we were sacrificing the
knight when the knight was
in c4 well now we're doing the same
thing knight to c5
forcing more or less the deflection if
you take with the bishop we promote
and you don't have any kind of any kind
of
fortress or anything like that
um and
after united fate there is 94 track it's
really gorgeous the fact that
the bishop even if it restricts those
two pawns it does stay on a czech bishop
over here and white can perfectly
utilize this idea
in order to win the game king somewhere
we take the bishop
and then there's no way for black to
stop the promotion of the b-pawn
and black is winning so here was the
second one i really hope you guys
enjoyed this one too
it's kind of nice i think with the
deflection with the two pawns trying to
promote and the opponent stopping it
i hope you guys liked it now i have
another
one as i said i try to kind of combine
the different themes so that you guys
have the opportunity to see
more themes if you have missed some of
the other videos
that i've made with studies i believe
they're still
on the sellers chess club's youtube page
if you are subscribed to the channel
uh you should be notified when
the club is putting videos online
i highly recommend it because the club's
youtube channel is probably one of the
best there's
always so much very interesting and very
good material
created by many top level players
and i think it is very important to be
subscribed
to this channel if you love chess and
you're trying to improve so
be sure to do that it's that easy you
just make a click
and that's it and then you're waiting
for the notification to pop
and for the live sessions like live
videos live lectures
uh that are happening throughout the
week
so what do we think about this position
this was created by kalashnikov
white to move what to do
clearly in this position black has this
knight attacked and um white has the
bishop attacked but
if if somehow something happens and
and why it gets to take the bishop and
then black taste tonight
probably there will not be an easy way
for them to actually
um
i win the game i mean for white but
anyways
there is a beautiful idea and that is
d7 um
someone else has said the seven in the
chat so well done good job for
that uh e6 is a nice
choice too but unfortunately it does not
work because black
does have quite some checks if you're
not careful
where you're going you may end up even
losing this so you have to be very very
cautious
say you push the pawn to try to promote
then
we'll check you and then wherever you go
we're going to check you again
and we're going to take this pawn so
he's going to go somewhere
we're gonna take this pawn and then
whenever they promote
we get to do what get to have a couple
of
fun facts and that is we're checking
them first
then we're taking and once again in this
position as in the previous one there
should be a way for black
to create a fortress and hold on to the
position
all right and there will be no progress
whatsoever for white
so e6 would have been very interesting
um knight knight c7
is another move that we want to consider
and
only after that we want to push d7 but
the problem is after this move
go bishop g8 e6
and now if they take
um d7
this is a gorgeous idea but um
and now um
there will be no way for y to really
progress this position this
should be a true it's kind of crazy
e6 in that position is also leading to
some
drawing ideas because after the check
black manages to take the pawn and if
you do push d7 and that's the point that
you should push because that's the pawn
that
gives you the opportunity of promotion
rook f5 right
and same thing happens after knight
takes g7 king takes g7
we take and then uh black should not
rush to grab that pawn black should try
to make sure they're stopping these two
pawns because now they're dangerous
they're really advanced the king can
support them and with the rook alone you
cannot really stop them so it's very
important to play
precise in this position rook d8 keeping
the d6 pawn protect
attacked so that you cannot push the e
pawn if the king comes in
you can start with a few checks and you
can see afterwards what you will do but
the checks are usually helpful because
they push the king away
and then black should be able to make a
draw
but guess what d7 many of you have
suggested this move
and you were right if you did suggest
this move you're definitely right even
if you didn't suggest it but you thought
about it
and you're waiting for me to show you
the correct solution
well this is it d7 attacking the rook
the rook needs to move somewhere and the
point is that now we play e6
so we're keeping the rook restricted
there we did not rush to move the knight
we are not threatening supposedly e7 yet
because if we do push it they will grab
the pawn and then the e7 pawn will be
hanging
very very soon
so in this position we're also
threatening to take the bishop so
suppose black is trying to escape by
playing bishop g8
what do you guys think should happen now
what should white do in this position
because clearly you cannot push he's
gonna take here and then that pawn is
hanging
and if you lose this pawn there's no way
you are winning
not even drawing anymore it is very
important to take advantage
look for the opponent's threat stop it
and then find a way to win
so king f5 is the correct move in this
position
because now here or
c7 pushed upon and promote and there's
nothing that black can do about it
oops so
if he takes here and that's a really
nice move
pawn takes and then the question is what
is it that we promote
you know how when i play blitz or bullet
if you guys are following me with the
streams
i have automatic promotion to a queen
but that's probably not the best idea
because if you have too many promotion
to a queen and you should promote
to another piece then that's the bad
situation obviously you cannot promote a
queen or rook because black will be
instilled made
so we're going to promote one knight i'm
not sure if black was able to actually
see this
because you know well it's a study but
i'm not sure if they would see
this but anyways um they would see it
under promotion exactly bishop takes e6
king takes c6 king to g8
king to king to h8 and
now ladies and gentlemen
and now we are dealing with a
zugzwang and the correct move for white
in this position
is i wonder if anyone can find it
and tell me what it is i'm not seeing
any
i'm not seeing any any uh any typos
knight d6 nope nope knight f6 yes
i have six zugsvang right he's
he doesn't have any moves other than
taking the knight
and now key to f7 okay king to
f7 or f8 if you want a faint okay sure
but then the point is you're pushing the
pawn you're promoting
and then you can meet to them so that's
a really cool idea i love this knight of
six move
with the zooxbang i hope you guys love
it too
all right and this was the solution for
the next position
now i do have another affect one i kind
of
you know love johannan effect i've told
you
in other streams and other um
life classes that um
he was he's the first and only
composer i think that i've ever met and
he was
very kind to myself and
angie melchen um because
um we were playing this tournament in uh
in netherlands and he was always sharing
after the
after the games we were hanging out to
have dinner
around the playing area and um
and he was sharing a lot of his really
cool studies not just his but some
other ones and so he's he's always going
to be special for me
and i like to share his
his studies whenever possible but
anyways in this position it is way to
move and we're trying to find the wing
effect sounds like an equation no for
some reason when i'm copying my
positions from chess base they
make this equal sign here for some
reason i'm not even sure why that's
happening but it is happening so
forget about that equal sign let's just
try to figure out what is happening here
we do have an extra rook with white but
black is threatening these kind of
annoying ideas where he's going to
promote his pawns
and then we've got nothing so it is very
important to come up with good ideas
ooh someone has already seen the
solution
and the correct first move is bishop d5
indeed
if you're trying to escape with the rook
so that you can somehow find a way to
promote your pawn
this crazy move is killing everything
because now if you take it then
obviously they promote so it makes no
sense and there's no
uh good restriction that would actually
help us
you know the creative fortress not at
all no so we're gonna go king to d2
for example right king to a2
and then he can check and then if you
take there's b2
and the best thing you can do is
sacrifice the bishop
maybe give one more check
and push h7 and whenever black promotes
whatever piece
obviously a queen we're gonna sacrifice
the the rook for it
then we're going to promote and this is
going to be a draw
but the point is with white we're trying
to win in this position
so bishop d5 as someone said in the
stream
is correct so we start with this check
he has to capture he does not have
a way out if he moves the king somewhere
then we will capture this pawn and after
that
he doesn't really have a way we can just
take the pawn and start marching the h
pawn and white is very very very easily
winning the game
the study
that's a bishop d5 check king takes now
the idea is that he's still threatening
the same thing b2
and then promotion so what to do with
white and here is this
gorgeous move that i love very much
because there's no other move
that can win here the position for white
h7 for example would not be so good
because b2
and then if you move king c4 and then
if you get to promote black also gets to
promote
eventually you do have to take whether
you take it now or later
and then you know that probably white
does have a way to
to for a position here but that's about
it
that's why in this position it's very
important to find this move
which is very very important king d2
nope it's not king d2
it's actually this gorgeous move long
castle what don't castle seriously yes
seriously long castle because this move
comes in with check
and white brings in the king to support
to restrict those pawns from promoting
and that's how white is going to be able
to win
if you check them they will take you
king c4 we can check them
and white
is winning because there's no way to
stop the h pawn
and that is the solution because here
here
oh by the way we we can put a couple
more moves queen
king takes and if he plays king c2 he's
still one move behind or two moves
behind
because now white promotes to a queen
controls that square
you can push and white is winning
nice good i'm glad you guys like it
i think this was a pretty cool position
by johanna effect once again
so sacrificing the bishop and then under
promotion too
but in the same time there's no way to
progress
moving on to the next position that i
have for you guys
i'm trying to share more today since
it's as i said the last day that
i maybe maybe maybe on thursday i'll
show something but probably not
but i think it's kind of cool to um
to see some of these studies and uh
and try to solve them of course i'm
going a little bit fast because i want
to
to to share more but you can always try
to
save the position and just you know not
look at it just save the position come
back
in a few minutes and you'll see later in
the video if you can
can come up with the solution but uh you
should spend the time trying to solve
them first of course
that's that would be good
who's move white white so in studies in
in studies it is always white to move in
problems i believe it's black and then
there's
also something else where
you can choose
whom you are when you create the
position you can choose whom
you want to start first but it's usually
white
so in this position it is really really
tricky that
we've got two pieces and these pawns for
the queen
but we're trying to do is trying to find
a way to trap the queen
and get our pawn promoted if we can
black's king is does not stay very well
it is somewhat restricted so what do we
do here with white
someone's saying knight g8 but after
knight g8 i go king h5
and if you push here to try to trap my
queen i'm going to escape this way and i
have plenty of checks to give you
and you're not going to make uh it's not
going to be
very easy to escape paul benko was
indeed a very strong
player but also a great composer and he
has composed
some amazing studies i believe i did
show one or two
last class but today i do not have paul
banco studies
there are lots of other very strong
players that have created studies
uh typically i recommend kubell or
who else roski i guess
you guys have other names then because
at this
time i guess um
can't think of more names kubo is the
one that
i probably solved the most
studies but yeah i don't have the book
with me here in romania so i didn't
choose those kind of
studies
you just did 19. no there's nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong the point is
that now unfortunately you don't have a
follow-up
four right to try to win because you
cannot push this bishop
um you cannot you cannot push this pawn
because the bishop is hanging and
you can still probably make a draw if
you go here and try to promote
because you black can give a few tricks
but if they stop with the checks then
white promotes you know
so that's why we don't give the check we
are playing f6
first and it's really gorgeous what's
happening here because you're thinking
how can you play f6 first you're giving
up a pawn
he's gonna capture it and he captures it
with track and it's a czech knight and
then you have no progress
why would you sacrifice this pawn it's
just completely silly
indeed it is completely seated but let's
not forget
a knight is an amazing piece that
restricts checks by the uh the
opponent's queen
okay so just because it's a check it
doesn't mean it's game over right it's a
checkmate okay we retreated the night
and it's a counter check guess what that
doesn't happen it's all for fun
but it's a really awesome counter check
knight f5
check the king has to go to h5 and now
we have this discovery so how do we do
it
well we're not rushing yet h4
moves like h3 do not work be very
careful
as you're giving the checks because now
there's this crazy move
that tries to make um
to black is trying to get the stalemate
and there isn't so much you can do
about it if you go there he keeps
checking oopsy
not that he keeps checking you
and this is a draw but
since we see that he has the check and
that's the only trick he has
we're going to play h4 to restrict it
now black's king
is completely fully 100 restricted
there's no so much he can do exactly
so now he can be fancy and be like haha
queen g5 check there you have it
stalemate it is
i'm going to be able to save myself done
deal
no it's not like that it's not done deal
king e5
we will obviously not take if we take
it's a stalemate okay so we
we don't take goku five and
then he can try to sacrifice the queen
again because of the way we have placed
our pieces and the way he was able to
bring the king on the edge of the board
maybe he's able to you know save himself
but
check for stalemate but obviously we
don't take if we take its stalemate
so we're hiding again right because the
knight can't control the follow-up
checks and it's protecting here as well
which is which is pretty awesome
um and then king g4
to finally try to escape with the king
maybe take the knight
obviously we protect the knight and now
black does not really have good moves
and this pawn is just going for the
promotion and there's nothing
you can do about it you can try to bring
in the king
the queen there to give one more check
but literally it's just one more check
then you could go 97 for example or the
king can move two but maybe 97 now
there's
no check i guess there's one more check
okay ah but
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry it's
it's it's this check
from from white that's why you cannot do
anything you need to move the king
somewhere and then we promote
and white is winning
that is it g7 gorgeous idea i think
black is trying some stalemates but no
it is white the one who is winning
let's try one more position one more
i hope you guys are enjoying it so far
what do you guys think about this
position well
clearly with white we have a piece down
what please down and
when you see something like this the
first thing you should think about is
what i have a piece down let me try to
take it
and you could think of this move and you
could just play it
and then well guess what you're gonna
make a draw and then you'll be like
oh man why didn't they try it harder why
didn't they try harder because here
um maybe queen f7 and black will have
that perpetual check idea
that will be kind of annoying so with
white you have to be very careful what
you take and when you take it
to make sure he will not be able to save
himself
let's not forget in this position
black's king does stay on some kind of
mate
right so if somehow the queen gets to d1
or e2 or even f3
it's going to be a checkmate and
there can be translates in in in studies
as well it doesn't have to be
in a middle game doesn't have to be in
end games
yeah when you get to play blitz games
and then you get into an
game i know it's really tough but
c4 everyone's saying c4 that's an
interesting choice i know you want to
play queen e2 but
if you do that i'm just going to play
queen e6 or queen eight maybe queen
eight to keep the knight protected
or maybe 26 i'm not sure which one maybe
six
because um if you take then i'm gonna
give you check
you go somewhere and then king h3 and
you're actually running out of checks
and i'm threatening a bunch of mates
and you cannot stop these you can
already stop it
explosion uh c4 is explosive
it's explosive but it's explosive for
white white is trying to
maybe not lose here but maybe even win
and c4 unfortunately gives black the
opportunity to get the activity of the
queen
right now he didn't really have activity
so since we do not want the opponent to
have the activity
something you have to remember from
endgames in general
um studies as well but what you have to
remember is
it's very important when you have queens
on the board
to try to centralize your queen from the
center the middle of the board the queen
controls so much
and it's just
it's it's very hard to to do much so
queen e5 this is a very strong and
beautiful move
still keeping the pressure on the night
but in the same time we won this mate
which was basically the whole reason why
we are
you know here uh
we want this mate so he has to go there
so that he stops the mate if you check
him he's gonna go queen here right
exactly exactly so we're going to check
him anyways it doesn't matter he's going
to go
queen g4 and then we'll check him again
and he's going to go queen g6 and he
will say okay i offer you a draw that's
fine
it's not too bad you cannot really take
my knight you probably want to but i'll
always have this activity with my queen
and most likely it's going to be a draw
so that's the reason after queen g6
white needs to come up with a good idea
and was that good idea anyone
nobody said this move surprising this is
my favorite move
if you've watched me even one time i
pretty much see it all the time in my
streams
in videos everywhere my favorite move
is g4 pawn to g4
that's usually my favorite move everyone
is like
g4 now everyone is like g4 yes that is
my favorite move the reason behind it
you can find it out in some youtube
videos i said it many times
i'm not going to share enough so that
you can go and research more videos
but anyways g4 is the idea
and now uh you cannot take with the king
obviously because you lose your queen
um and you cannot take with the queen
you can move the king if you want to
um you cannot take of course because the
queen is hanging and if you go there
also the queen is hanging so the only
move
possible move is pawn takes
exactly if i can find the g4 square
that's the square l sign but usually i
must
to to sign a specific other square so
it's not going to happen that but
anyways so he takes right so we take
advantage of the fact that the knight is
out of plane
not so important and we try to take
advantage to see if we can find a way to
win
he has to go king h4 and now we continue
checking him and it's
really beautiful i think all these
tracks he goes back
and now you want to try to make the king
it's always been the whole idea to try
to make the opponent's king
so king g3 threatening a checkmate
once again once again and black does not
have
any checks that was also very very
important
so white how white put the queen on each
seven
that's just amazing now black needs to
moving the queen
move out the queen actually so the king
can go back home and
avoid the mate but guess what no we
don't let you
we do not let you avoid that uh
and then after queen d5
mate but there's nothing you can do
because there's mate anyways here in h4
that was that guys
after pointing g4 why not f5
after queen takes g4 when
i'm not quite sure where did i do that
that's a g4 after g4 quintex g4 is not
possible
because it's pinned so king takes our
pawn takes but king takes i said that
already we're taking the queen
and pawn takes you're saying five of the
points no f5 if you play he will take
your queen
and that's why it was very important to
give these checks okay
the king went and it it's just super
crazy that he cannot
just go there and then the mate is
happening
so guys that was uh that was that
i hope you guys i hope you guys enjoyed
this video i hope you guys enjoy the
studies that i've
come up with i didn't come up with i
chose for today's class with the
different themes
kind of review some promotions some
cellmates some zugsvan
some maids because you usually don't see
so many mates
in studies it's usually like a win or
it's a
you know draw through cell mate or a
repetition
but look you're also getting to see a
mate on the board which i think is
pretty awesome
um what else i really hope
really really hope you enjoyed this if
you haven't done so yet
please do follow sorry subscribe
to san luis chess clubs youtube channel
you don't need to do anything it's all
free just click the subscribe button
and you will be notified whenever we go
live
um also if you like this video thanks
for giving us a thumbs up
we will know what to continue creating
for
the club's youtube channel
i hope i'm going to see
many of you soon both on youtube and on
twitch
have a wonderful rest of the evening and
see you in my next videos bye for now